القوة العظمى الجديدة في الصين Battlefield 12 إلى
60 ميلًا فوق الأرض منخفضة جدًا بالنسبة للأقمار
الصناعية المرتفعة جدًا بالنسبة لمعظم الطائرات في
الستراتوسفير أو كما تسميها الصين بالقرب من
الفضاء في عام 2018 ،
قالت الصحيفة الرسمية للجيش الصيني إن الفضاء القريب
أصبح ساحة معركة جديدة في Modern
Warfare قد هبطت فيليكس  بالعودة بأمان إلى
الأرض منذ أكثر من عقد من الزمان ، فإن
قفزة السقوط الحر فيليكس بومغارتنر من
الفضاء القريب أسرت العالم
وربما لفتت انتباه
الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ في وقت مبكر من عام
2014 ، فقد أمر القوات الجوية الصينية
بتسريع التكامل الجوي والفضائي
وشحذها.  القدرات الهجومية والدفاعية ،
أعطى الأولوية لتطوير
الأسلحة التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت والطائرات بدون طيار التي تعمل بالطاقة الشمسية
والبالونات على ارتفاعات عالية ، وكلها
مصممة للرحلات الفضائية القريبة في
طبقة الستراتوسفير ، إن الهواء الرقيق في
الصين ليس وحده الولايات المتحدة وآخرون
قفزوا إلى سباق الفضاء القريب
مرة أخرى في عام 2012 بكاميرا سي إن إن  التقطت
المنظر من
100000 قدم على منطاد الطقس على ارتفاعات عالية ، وكان
بالون التجسس الصيني المشتبه به ،
والذي يزعم البنتاغون أنه كان يحمل
كاميرات عالية الدقة
ومعدات مراقبة إلكترونية ، كان من الممكن أن يلتقط
صورًا واضحة وضوح الشمس لمناطق حساسة للغاية
ويراقب
الاتصالات العسكرية في بعض النواحي
متفوقًا على الأداء الصيني المتقدم.
الأقمار الصناعية للتجسس عندما يكون لديك شيء
يصل ارتفاعه إلى سبعين ألف ومائة
ألف قدم ، يمكنك رؤية الأفق على
بعد أكثر من 300 ميل ، وهو شيء
لا يمكنك فعله من طائرة الآن ،
يمكنك فعل ذلك من قمر صناعي ولكن
القمر الصناعي باهظ الثمن  للوصول إلى
هناك ، يتطلب الأمر القليل من التخطيط
لإطلاقه
ومن ثم لا يمكنك تغيير
ما يفعله بالضبط أو إصلاحه بمجرد وجوده ،
يقوم الغواصون البحريون بتمشيط المياه قبالة
ساحل كارولينا حتى يتمكن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي من تجميع
الحطام معًا  من بين ما تسميه الصين منطاد
طقس مدني
على عكس بالونات الطقس هذه التي تم إطلاقها
يدويًا من كيب كانافيرال فلوريدا ،
كان البالون الصيني ضخمًا يبلغ ارتفاعه حوالي 200
قدم مع حمولة تصل إلى 90 قدمًا ربما
تعمل بالطاقة الشمسية بحجم ثلاث
حافلات مدينة ، وهو مصدر مطلع على
إحاطات الكونغرس حول
قال البالون إن بعض المكونات مكتوبة باللغة الإنجليزية ،
وليس من الواضح ما إذا كانت مصنوعة في
أمريكا أو بلد غربي آخر